and in a coma hi Steve Kaufman more hair
the linguist Institute for my link
called Tom Doyle no sitcom subtly
tamanna can you dim you hope you or say
to your [ __ ] come to llamada de o come
all ye liner what a joyful now I tae ha
goes peepee time I Demi oh holy beep
it's an áááhole
gko Eunice Jana Corrie job we hope [ __ ]
[ __ ] man [ __ ] why Johnny D era create a
nice Tang tang kodachi click tango born
or your high beta y'all hi ba-gawk-oh
technology come Cory okay hurry up John
ho Chi come there my man down
what you ho chi gong yet come now Diane
okay high hop that be baby time find a
door didn't gynae a mai tai chi yong IDK
girl you say cottagey tamanho diana
crazy
ty see Tai Chi Johanna Diane holy lay on
link or they come you a nail a link net
they hire you soon job
hold all your hatred annoy you you
veneer hi I'm Graham poachy pop Neko you
go on company you hold the scene John
wake up god damn dude a [ __ ] boy 10
holder geology y'all tie Tiger see honey
they [ __ ] up the Gina may hi-yah
I want a guy to come Yahoo the father
Banda me ha me
you an a hi a con the big on ho Deena
they don't say dumb doji Pena Illinois
you don't know who you're hanging to the
norm a high e sinto so you know more for
you need a link come their name you
wanna come young high what they Linc
Hawk they wanna k1 and they tell her mom
oh yeah so tomar take our tutor gone
yeah
they are holy or they they tutor come
yet Yahoo e7 Jonah to the rebounding go
away come they may come you only need a
high link now jump the whole come hey
mom
nail a link oh I need all vanity oh
sorry